[Music]
michelle's with us in cleveland ohio hi
michelle how are you
hi dave i'm good thanks for taking my
call sure what's up
um twofold i have um i got an esop
distribution from a company that i
worked for
and it's about 1.4 million
sitting in
a schwab account it's in an ira and i'm
with everything that's going on i'm
afraid about having all my eggs in one
basket
and my husband and i are both retired
i'm 61 he's 67
but we still have a mortgage
and a home equity line of credit
um
we don't have any credit cards we're
debt-free in the credit cards and up
until last week we had two paid off cars
but
an engine sieved in one of our cars so
we had to go buy a car this week um
my question is whether to given what's
going on in the world and you know the
great reset i was just watching i have
glenn beck's book and i was just
watching your program that aired today
um
i'm just a little afraid
obviously of having all my eggs in one
basket
and given what's going on in the world
if we should just
take i think there's about 160 000 that
we could take out in cash and just pay
everything off you should do that anyway
but not because of the fear of what's
going on in the world it's a smart
financial move
you should
you've got a million dollars you should
not be carrying around a home mortgage
with a couple hundred grand you ought to
be paying it off
okay well that was that was my thought
process too but not because not because
of the great reset just because it's
smart to pay off your mortgage
okay okay then and same thing never
borrow money on a car again you're a
millionaire come on girl
i know i was planning on paying it off
next year how about just never borrowing
on a car again
you're not a broke person you're a
millionaire
now with the rest of the money with the
rest of money what i would do is sit
down with a smart vester pro click
ramsey solutions and click smart buster
pro and find somebody in the investment
business that can help you do a rollover
and get that diversified across several
types of mutual funds and give you a
little more safety
yeah i'm with you i would not have it
all in one account but i'm not sure what
you've got with schwab there necessarily
you may not really be in one account but
i'd be in several different mutual funds
with that much money and i'd be
debt-free you go borrow money on cars
you're a millionaire
this is the ramsey show